hey guys so this week has been
absolutely mental so much stuff going on
and I think the only way to really do it
justice is to kind of go through a bye
game so on Saturday last week but before
I filmed my vlog I went to my colleges
summer ball some Pierce College presents
the roaring 20s and I mean hopefully
about that there's a link on the screen
there's a link in the description police
again seen that ready check it out
because it's one of the best things
about Oxford then the day after on
Sunday night I went to formal at Merton
College so I come from a school where
maybe one or two people get the Oxbridge
per year if that and my name is bump
here we actually a to public at Oxford
alone and that was me and my friend
Chris who is at Merton college reading
chemistry and four degrees even though
we go to different colleges we've kept
in touch so we buy them in going to the
pub we've been doing these formal swaps
so I went over to Merton College just
turn around them for starts we had this
then the main course I have this because
I'm vegetarian but Chris had this and
then we both had this for dessert and
then after we went up to this room which
is his middle common room we had this
one it was really nice although
admittedly after the ball alcohol wasn't
first thing on my mind then on Monday as
always tension went back to doing work
so this week I was revising geophysical
fluid dynamics which are stuff that I
did two terms ago and newcomers term and
incorporating new material which is the
only that course actually have this term
which is advanced geophysical fluid
dynamics
talked about that a little bit in the
past some stuff that was covering in
particular on Monday were raspberries
and Kelvin waves which are internal
waves in the atmosphere then on
Wednesday or when it's the university
computing services to present the talk
on YouTube and Oxford practices October
access generally refers to any activity
which is done to try and dispel there
was misconceptions about Oxford and I
suppose in a way try and convince them
to apply so I was presenting a talk
basically outlining what I'd be doing
with this YouTube channel my colleges
YouTube channel and proposing a project
which I haven't talked about this
channel yet and I'm holding back on
talking about for what the university
could possibly do next year as a
vlogging project but hopefully more on
that in the future my friend Rob came up
with me just to see me presenter talk is
a bit of moral support and he was meant
to film it but he said that afterwards
they completely forgot to film because
he found
- interesting so uh thanks Rob you can
blame him for not having any footage but
thank you for coming along I really
appreciate it
it was awesome on Wednesday that I
started working on the theoretical work
for this week which was a revision
problem sheet that was set with my tutor
and that covered a lot of things that we
did in first term things like functional
calculus and Fineman diagrams and what
sort of thing mathematically actually
represent other things like things with
exotic men names like hafsteinn prima
cough transformations and Bogoliubov
transformation easily things like that
it's actually quite nice that now I'm
doing these division problem sheets all
these things which kind of separate in
my head before and our coalescing into
these ideas and I finally start getting
it properly which is of course why the
service promises then on Thursday we had
our physics society talk which was given
by dr. Allen bahu is a particle physics
lecturer here Oxford he lectured me last
year and is also the head of the UK
Atlas collaboration when Atlas is the
main experiment at the LHC in Geneva his
talk was not on the main thing that's
been associated with the LHC which is
the Higgs boson but was actually about a
sort of separate part for this looking
at supersymmetry which is this idea that
all particles in the standard model of
physics have a supersymmetric much
heavier counterpart which are based
likely for different physical laws the
idea being that the most stable out of
these civis metric particles is the most
likely candidate for explaining dark
matter dark matter is a hypothesized
substance which explains some galactic
dynamics which we otherwise can't
explain just given our understanding of
gravity event on Saturday morning I went
out and filmed the colleges Boat Club
doing an outing on the river Bradley and
involved me going on this little
motorized launch with the cruise Kokua
shouting at them with a megaphone and it
was me leaning over her shoulder with a
camera which was a it was incredible it
was a really amazing experience and
there was some really sick footage which
isn't just for me it's also useful for
training purposes for them so they can
improve their technique now Jamie asked
a really interesting question in his
video on Thursday which I'm actually
gonna shamelessly steal this question
was what are you most proud of in your
life I think that often people are so
negative about themselves and saying oh
I can't do this I can't do that
they never have other things they can do
they're not
proud of the things they have done so
you're really interested to hear from
you guys what is the thing that you're
most proud of that you've achieved in
your life and based on the people that
watch these videos and people who
thinking of flight or oxygen but we're
gonna get some really interesting
responses jamie is to showing that you
missed the model Inquirer I've actually
never been down to see that it's always
been something I've wanted to do so
maybe next year we could both go down
and do it again and do like a joint
collaboration blog oh you have a
fantastic third week I will see you on
Thursday and I will see you guys at home
on Sunday